what are your thoughts about longevity
right now um I think that longevity
I certainly have certainly come to two
better terms with longevity um in in the
sense that I think it's a it's a much
more solvable problem than what I used
to think when I was living in Germany
and I think that there's several
different fallacies around longevity
that when you ask people you know do you
want to do you want to live indefinitely
they say no and they think that with
living definitely we mean you know like
living and healthfully indefinitely but
um to me what really woke me up to this
is if you would plot if you would ask
people when is it bad to die in your
life right they would usually think that
it's not so bad to die as a baby because
you haven't made any investments here
towards your future self then it gets
progressively worse as you get older it
gets worse and ways to die as a teenager
you've now you at school you're making
you know investments to what your future
and you invest in your ecosystem around
you people value you value them and then
you know if you make all those
investments eventually you have this
life narrative you cash out on them you
have a good job and then it gets less
and less bad to die and as you get older
and as you've you know how to your
perfect life narrative and like you know
it's as wholesome one one narrow
narration of life circle circle but what
I don't agree that it gets worse
today but I don't agree that it gets
less bad to die at the end of it I
actually think that the reason why we
think that it gets less better died at
the end of it is maybe for three reasons
maybe we don't even think that maybe we
think that elderly people think that but
they don't actually do my grandma told
me that she doesn't she is really scared
of death and she really loves everyone
around me a lot everyone around her Lord
secondly if they do think that it gets
less bad to die when they're old then
that's I think because they think
because they're frail and old right and
because they are ill they have the
disease of aging which we all have but
they have it as a at a much more
advanced level so they are just
unhealthy and no one wants to live in an
unhealthy way
if they you know we're to give him back
like youthful vigor then I'm certain
they would they would want to live
longer and then the third one is that
even if they say that they don't I think
that is absurd
protection mechanism given that they
know that they're going to die in that
we don't have the cell is easier to help
prevent them die and I think people just
shut down right before that it was God
and village and in the afterlife and now
it's just like oh it's okay I've had my
life narrative and that is the
psychological tool that they use I think
to to to kind of down to update their
preferences downward or their
expectations of life downward and to
just expect this whereas I think what we
should be saying is like that that's not
the default right it doesn't have to be
the end point of life and I think once
if if we this is weird almost like you
know shake an egg problem you know you
first have to present them with some
viable solution until they were actually
you know really want to go for it but I
do think that there's a lot more
well-being to be attained and and and I
of the belief that all of the hope
really then that I will not have to die
yeah I want to see how long civilization
prospers and how it does your honor II
think it's it's all about the 27 club
any White House Kurt Cobain Jimi Hendrix
Jim Morrison coming in balls to the wall
live your life don't give a [ __ ] and get
out at before you thirty all right well
then I would have four more for my years
I've known well you know are you are you
living your life with that zest of those
superstars then left their mark and and
and will never die as long as you know
we continue to listen to their music and
study their life and I do but also I
mean I'm coming here at the closet here
and which is not much of a closet 7
Cisco but I mean I'm signing up to
cryonics I'm signed up to forever labs
I'm doing intermittent fasting so I am
taking steps toward ensuring that I
won't end if even if
I even if I do die and which I think
might be the wrong terminology then at
least it might just be you know a
vitrified state for a while before that
changes again yeah I hope that we can
get to a point where we don't need to
leave our consciousness for a period of
time and then come back hopefully we can
just stay through the whole thing
that's good that you're signed up for it
and exploring it